Después de acampar y recorrer grandes distancias
en bicicleta, tú decides regresar directo
a casa en bicicleta, viajando a una velocidad constante.
Después de 2 horas tú te encuentras a 10 km. de tu casa, después de 2 horas tú te encuentras a 10 km de tu casa,
y después de 4 horas de viaje te encuentras a 5 km. de casa. Una vez iniciado el viaje en bicicleta,
¿cuántas horas te tomará regresar a casa?
De hecho esto es una t, te tomará regresar a casa...
Vamos a poner en una tabla estos datos.
Mi tabla va a ser de tiempo y distancia,
tiempo 2 horas distancia 10 km.
Ahora el tiempo de 4 horas, la distancia es de 5 km.
Como se viaja a una velocidad o rapidez constante,
vamos a ver ¿cuál es este valor constante?
Cuando en el tiempo paso de 2 a 4,
se incrementa en 2... se incrementa en 2...
y en la distancia paso de 10 a 5,
es decir, resto 5, -5.
Si el tiempo se llegara a incrementar otras
2 horas, es decir, pasara de 4 a 6,
se incrementa otras 2 horas, ¿qué pasará con esto?
Éste se va a decrementar en 5,
éste va a pasar acá, se decrementa en 5, 5 menos 5
va a ser 0, quedando a 0 km. de casa, es decir,
que aquí ya llegamos.
Aquí hemos resuelto lo que nos preguntan,
nos va a llevar 6 horas regresar a casa.
Ahora voy a hacer una pregunta que no nos
hace aquí, que es ¿qué tan lejos estábamos
cuando iniciamos el viaje de regreso?
Encontramos algunos datos previos.
Vamos a copiar esto y peguémoslo más abajo
para hacer espacio.
Con estas maravillosas herramientas...
tomo esto... vamos a hacer un poquito de espacio
aquí hacia abajo...
completamos la línea...
¿qué pasa si yo a este 2 le resto 2?
si paso de aquí a acá y le resto 2, aquí me
va a quedar un 0 y si a este 10 en lugar de restarle 5,
le sumo 5, si paso de aquí a
acá y le sumo 5, me va a quedar 15,
así que estábamos a 15 km
de distancia cuando iniciamos el viaje.
Otra forma de pensar en esto... quito esto de acá...
es pensar que iniciemos en 0 y le aumentamos 2,
y a este 15 le restamos 5,
mantenemos la misma proporción y estos datos
se nos van cumpliendo,
se sigue conservando esta proporción.
Vamos a graficarlo para terminar de comprender
mejor este resultado.
Dibujemos nuestros ejes, nuestro eje horizontal,
nuestro eje vertical, éste es el tiempo
y éste es la distancia.
Hagamos las divisiones, en "t" llega hasta 6...
vamos a ver éste es 2...
4...
6...
y en distancia se llega hasta 15...
vamos a ver, que sea más o menos...
aquí, 5...
10... 15...
5, 10 y 15...
Y ahora encontremos nuestras
intersecciones en "t" y "d".
Tenemos la intersección en "d" cuando el
tiempo es igual a 0, es 0, 15,
este punto de acá, 0, 15.
Y mi intersección en "t", cuando "d" es igual a 0,
que es éste y es 6, 0...
6, el valor en "t"... 0 en "d", 6, 0.
Y ahora unimos esos puntos para tener nuestra línea,
es una línea recta,  ya lo habíamos dicho,
porque la velocidad es constante,
unimos estos dos puntos.
Y una pregunta que quizás se estén
haciendo ustedes es,
¿cómo podemos cuantificar la velocidad o la rapidez en al que viajábamos?
Bueno, ésta está relacionada con
la inclinación de esta línea.
La inclinación o la pendiente es el cambio en el eje vertical con respecto al eje horizontal.
Ésta, su pendiente, se define como
el cambio en el eje vertical,
que es el de la distancia, entre el cambio en el eje horizontal, que es del tiempo.
Y de la tabla, vimos que el cambio en la
distancia es de -5...
-5, entre el cambio en tiempo
que es de más 2, 2.
Así que esta pendiente es igual a -5/2.
Veámoslo aquí en la gráfica,
¿cuál es este cambio?
Del punto, 2, 10, de este punto 2, 10,
éste de acá al 4, 5, a este otro punto de acá, 4, 5, éste...
Nuestro cambio en la distancia, de aquí a
acá es de 5, hacia abajo, -5
y el cambio en el tiempo es de aquí a acá,
de 2 a 4, es de 2, -5, 2.
Así es que la distancia, que se viajó, es
igual a 15 menos 5/2 por el tiempo recorrido.
Y es bueno ver todos estos aspectos de este
problema aunque nos haya llevado más tiempo
y cálculos, que el resolver solo la pregunta
que nos hacían originalmente.